I think Bobby Jordan was super funny
yeah uh imagine now Ike Baron holds
Bobby Lee and Jordan Peele a pilot it's
it's is it 30 minutes uh I think we did
a short like it was like 20 minutes do
you still have it somewhere I could find
it yeah yeah I remember the the there
was a scene where we like went to go hit
on some girls at a bar yeah and we all
like dressed up and what outfits that we
thought made us look hot yeah and you
were wearing like jeans and a t-shirt I
was wearing a suit and Jordan was
dressed like Morpheus from The Matrix
you have like a little glasses I
remember that I remember the ladies we'd
like to have him come to a party with us
I remember that I remember that I
remember that yeah